charles baudelaire a écrit les fleurs du
niagara
[Rires]
alors nabila voici la question sur
quinze ouvrages célèbres de la
littérature française
combien de titres nabila peut-elle
compléter correctement un seul titre
entre deux et cinq titres entre 6 et 10
titres ou plus de dix titres sur car je
sur 15 je lui donnerai le début elle
devra donner la fin de l' ouvrage est là
on va voir on va
nabila ou pour être voté aussi pour
voient des prises et où il ya pas d moi
alors j'ai mis un d'accord mais alors et
vous jouez le jeu bien sûr nabila venez
avec moi on va s'installer après je ne
sais pas
attention la ville à 15 titres vous
devez les complique
attention alphonse daudet a écrit les
lettres de mon nom
[Rires]
ne faites pas ça le fond se donnait pas
lui d'abord je participe
oui mais bon alors aux rouges et les
noirs
oui la comtesse de ségur a écrit des
malheurs deux sauces sophie oui bien sûr
c'est bon charles baudelaire a écrit les
fleurs du niagara fleur du mal
molière a écrit le bourgeois gentil
gentil gars le bourgeois gentilhomme ne
fait pas exprès la ville a franchement
non ok attention marcel pagnol a écrit
la gloire la gloire ou lamar non la
gloire de mon père
beau marché écrit le barbier 2 barbès
[Applaudissements]
jusqu'à l'île
c'est bien c'est bien comme c'est vrai
que ces bruits bien c'était brouillard
des bons titres loti débat trouve des
boutiques la fontaine écrit la fable le
lièvre et la tortue bien dostoïevski a
écrit crime et passion châtiment
flaubert écrit madame de fontenay normal
madame bovary hemingway qui le vieil
homme et la mer c'est la mer
je prends je te placer l'espèce le
projet on le prend tolstoï a écrit anna
condat
anna anna karénine george orwell a écrit
1980 4 sunu a écrit l'ars de la poule
l'art de la guerre et enfin maupassant
écrit bull deux sucres bull 2s sucre
boules de sucre ils essaient de me
siffler j'adore effet l'hôtel gardé les
l'alliance ares de rabbi jacob black
heaven paradis latin du possible et
alors ces bouts de suivre avant d'aller
au travail
franchement moi le bouchage et bien
pourquoi quelqu'un le bourgeois
gentilhomme faut le prendre
le bourgeois gentilhomme c'est vrai le
bon choix dans pigalle c'est presque
envie de l'europe mais franchement